SWIM.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THEY CREATE A LOT OF FUN CONTENT
OVER THERE, INCLUDING THE SHOW
"RICK AND MORTY," WHICH IS AN
AEMMY AWARD-WINNING SERIES.
GETTING READY FOR SEASON FIVE
PREMIER THIS SUNDAY JUNE 20TH
AND ONE OF THE STARS IS A FAN OF
OUR SHOW.
>>> THANKS, ERNIE, FOR HAVE
RELIGION ME -- FOR HAVING ME ON
THE SHOW.
IT'S NICE TO BE HERE.
I AM DISAPPOINTED THAT YOU DID
NOT TELL ME THAT I NEEDED TO
WEAR A BLUE/GRAY TYPE SUIT ON
THE SHOW.
I WOULD HAVE BEEN MORE PREPARED,
YOU DROPPED THE BALL.
WHATEVER, IT'S FINE.
I WAS KIND OF NERVOUS COMING,
IT'S LIKE, I'M A TEENAGER AND
THEN, CORPORATE SYNERGY, AND
THEY IS SAID I COULD TALK TO
SHAQ WHICH IS SUPER COOL.
AND IF I DID A REALLY, REALLY
GOOD JOB ON THE INTERVIEW, I
WOULD BE FEATURED ON THE NEW
KELLY CLARKSON SHOW, AND THAT'S
KIND OF WHAT MY ANGLE IS.
I'M GLAD I GOT TO BE ON P.
>> YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY RIGHT
NOW TO TALK TO SHAQ IF YOU HAVE
SOMETHING ON YOUR MIND.
>> UM, DO YOU LIKE SPACE?
>> YES, I LOVE BASS AND I LOVE
YOU ALL --
>> SPACE.
>> OH, SPACE, I THOUGHT YOU SAID
BASS.
I LOVE SPACE.
>> DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION FOR
SUMMER?
>> SUMMER, IS YOUR NAME -- ARE
YOU NAMED AFTER ANYONE, THE
MONTHS OR THAT'S THE REASON, HOW
DID SUMMER BECOME YOUR NAME?
WHEN YOUR PARENTS GAVE IT TO
YOU, WAS THERE A REASON?
>> YEAH, I DON'T KNOW, IT'S A
VERY, VERY BASIC NAME.
YOU KNOW, FOR A TEENAGE GIRL.
I THINK THAT'S WHY THEY NAMED ME
THAT.
>> YOU ARE ANYTHING BUT BASIC.
>> THANK YOU, I APPRECIATE THAT.
I WONDER IF YOU COULD, WOULD YOU
GUYS COME VISIT US SOMETIME IN
THE RICK AND MORTTY-VERSE, ARE
YOU UP FOR THAT?
>> CHUCK?
>> I'M NOT OPPOSED TO THE RICK
AND MORTY-VERSE, WHAT DO YOU
LISTEN TO NOW?
>> JUICE WORLD AND LIL NAZ-Q,
YOU GUYS HAVE NO IDEA WHO I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
>> CHUCK DOESN'T KNOW, HE HAS NO
TEENAGE KIDS.
>> I SEE, IT'S COOL.
>> WHAT DO YOU HAVE IN STORE FOR
SEASON FIVE WITHOUT GIVING TOO
MUCH AWAY.
>> THERE'S FAMILY CENTRIC
EPISODES WHERE THEY DO COOL
STUFF TOGETHER.
AND A EPISODE THAT I DON'T KNOW
IF I WOULD SHOW A CHILD IT.
PROBABLY A LITTLE TOO MATURE.
>> THAT'S MAYBE WHY IT'S ON
ADULT SWIM PROBABLY.
>> EXACTLY, EXACTLY.
SO THERE'S DEFINITELY MATURE
AUDIENCE STUFF GOING DOWN.
AND THEN, I DON'T KNOW IT'S
GOING TO BE FUN.
IT'S LIKE A CRAZY SHOW IF YOU
HAVE NOT SEEN IT.
THEN, I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU
HAVE BEEN LIVING FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS BECAUSE WE --
>> YOU INVITED US ON THE SHOW,
DIDN'T YOU?
>> I DID.
I DID.
YOU HAVE TO COME VISIT US.
I MEAN, JUST COME LIKE TO A
REALM OR A MENTION OR C-137 OR
ANY OF THE OTHER ONES THAT
EXIST.
>> HE IS ALWAYS IN IT ANYWAY.
CHARLES IS IN THAT SPACE ANYWAY.
>> ARE YOU?
VERY GOOD.
YEAH.
>> SO YOU GUYS KIND OF PUT THE
FUN IN DYSFUNCTIONAL, DON'T YOU?
>> ESPECIALLY IF YOUR
GRANDFATHER INTEREST SOMEBODY
WHO TRAVELS THROUGH SPACE AND A
BIT PSYCHO PATHIC.
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT IT MUCH,
BECAUSE NARCCISIM IS IN OUR
FAMILY A BIT.
IF SOMEBODY GETS IN YOUR WAY,
YOU JUMP SHIP TO ANOTHER
UNIVERSE AND IT'S FINE.
IT'S COOL.
>> RICK AND MORTY, SEASON FIVE
PREMIER ON SUNDAY.
JUNE THE 20TH.
SUMMER, IT'S BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
PLEASURE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> YES, THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> LOVE YOU, SUMMER, LOVE YOU,
SUMMER.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.